[Music]
good morning this is really a pleasure
to be here and to have the first talk
after the nice stop before today we will
speak about how to use deep learning in
order to help foot recognition for
monitoring foot intake so why do you
think it is important if you go to the
statistics for example in diabetics
people so diabetes is really a panda me
here we have 371 million people all over
the world that have diabetes and it is
growing that is only in the peniel's
will have 550 million people data that
have diabetics and even if that is for
these people it is very important to
provide them tools in order to improve
their nutrition if we think about
obesity obesity is also a very big
problem for that for the world for the
civilization for our planet we have 10%
of all the adult population is obese and
these people just to show for example
they used to spend 25% more in their
health care and they used to live 10
years less than the average person so
this is really a very important problem
for all over the world and the worst
news is that this tendency is growing
and this is growing in USA but it'll
still also growing in Europe in England
in Switzerland even in Spain where we
have this so famous Mediterranean diet
in fact in Spain the children they have
the highest rate of obesity in Europe
out of we have the Mediterranean diet so
what happens here so the point is that
when we think about how to help people
in today in measuring the nutrition in
trying to make them more who
even shelter so for the healthy habits
what we always reduce to the two main
reasons this is physical activities and
diet so for the physical activities all
of us we have Fitbit we have in our
smartphone a lot of for already
installed apps even if we are not aware
that are measuring counting our steps
but what about nutrition do is there any
way to measure what people eat so when
we when professional professional people
dietitians want to know how people eat
they ask them to feel in this this food
questionary so they should try to down
to write down here what they eat in the
morning midday afternoon etc do you know
what is the difference between what they
put in this paper and what is the
reality 35 percent it was quantified so
because nutritionists saw that this is
not the right way they did they define
it of food frequency questionnaire ease
and food frequency questionnaire is a
very long questioning that ask questions
like how many violet eggs did you eat
this month how many croissants with
chocolate we do it this month etc can we
think about asking all the questions
about all the food possible so
definitely this is not the right way so
let us think about and we are not the
first that thought that this is
important and that's why there are
different digital Diaries they try to do
this process easier so we have to the
expert people lose it My Fitness Pal
chronometer fat secret well you can down
write down all that you need the point
is that we don't do this we don't like
to write down or everything what we did
and that's why it is not working at this
moment out of it could be very helpful
and the idea is to to help day to people
so how many of you have seen people they
go to the restaurant and take the photo
and they do smartphone and make a
picture
right several of them and it is much
easier to take a picture and then the
the algorithm behind to process this and
then to construct automatically this
diet diary
so this is our deal so what what how to
help to clean to create automatically
these Diaries for food in tank
monitoring of course this is not the
first one and there is also the
alternative so there are now the some of
the the application they are trying to
do this and later try to optimize this
process like first and pellucid they
they also say they are doing this up
completely automatically applying foot
recognition algorithms ok but how many
are foods they are they recognizing how
many foods are there so according to the
Wikipedia this very well cited and
consulted her reference we have 8000
very basic food categories but in
general we are speaking about 200,000
food category ok so is it possible
really to do foot recognition with
200,000 categories well this is a
challenge and why it is a challenge
because if we think about all kinds of
food as you see this is not just
recognizing here it is a pedestrian or
it is a car it is much more complicated
so for example can you say what is this
one
put yes and what category is here and
how many different foods will you have
here so it's really complicated
yeah but anyway we try to approach the
problem so if we try to summarize the
problem the problem is that the
difficulties of the automatic hotel
Commission is that we have a very high
very huge intraclass variation for
example this oh this is apple pie also
it out of letís be very different and
also we have very ambiguous definitions
so what is the from the class is it a
pie is it a apple pie it is apple pie
with cream how many categories we
shouldn't define there are a lot of
inter-caste molarity different
thickening put they can look very
similar like fried bread or our steak
and there are a lot of mixed items in
the same image so this is really
challenging problem and then what we
because the problem is very difficult we
need a huge data set in order to try and
the worst one news is that this huge
data set should be annotated it should
be supervised so do you know any
powerful tool in order for data
processing in order to address a very
complicated problem with large amounts
of data all of us with hands we read
every day about deep learning and indeed
this is a really really very powerful
news so very powerful technology if you
go to Google Scholar that is like today
reference for all of us in science and
look on which are the most influential
papers last last two years you will see
that from the first seven five are on
deep learning and then we have house of
or a four in this case for R&D deep
learning and then we have two about
health specially on obesity and and we
have some about also about physic
saturated okay so this is really
challenging is really promising and the
definitely today we don't deep learning
we will not have all these successes
where we speak
when we see about drug discovery about
autonomous driving
about security and video surveillance
about media entitlement in-depth
entertainment for video captioning
videos etc etc so and even for deep and
with the planet today big companies are
trying to help to the really very global
and important problems like climate and
energy saving etc now how can we use it
is that is another fact is that today
the proven kissable better than humans
in a very different project light of the
problems like object recognition
lip-reading
high-end surveillance facial recognition
of debate searches license plate plate
readers it ain't even go for breast
tomosynthesis or for cancer diagnosis
okay so another I like very much this
this example so today diploma career it
even good artists so they are able to
paint the same picture in different
styles in in Bangor corn Burnett and
Suzanne Styles etc even analog like
example I like this is the first after
piece that has been created by the
planning cat here it was thought by by
somebody but really authors of for this
amount to somebody to pieces my to
people that like up to deep learning key
said this moment in the hype cycle yeah
this is a very big hesitation and and
for for a solving really complicated
problems and this is not this is very
logical because we if we think about if
we see how science has been evolving we
see that in fact we have in the fourth
quarter face of the scientific science
paradigms that is now today we are are
in a stage where we have a low
the data and also we have a lot of
software a lot of information knowledge
and also very good models how to put
this together this is the challenge of
our face at this moment in this moment
so for in order to do this and we need
to think about how to put together data
resources and models and if we think
about these three important pieces in
order to do something meaningful so
which of the components we have already
so if you think about resources so today
we have very powerful GPUs that are able
to process big amount of data so they
have ability to process 200 times that
is two orders by a bigger amount of
information and we are speaking just
last two thousand last two years and
also we have we can use deep using in
the cloud that is very helpful for many
scientists up from point of view of data
we generated as much data as that is
last two years originated as month
data's all the civilization before so we
are speaking about today about million
millions of the text enter images and
videos etc so today we have a lot of
data that definitely are very important
in order to address these difficult
problems like for example today every
day
103 millions of spam emails are sent
nobody will argue right about it okay
now how to use this information in order
to train our algorithms okay we are in
the this stage where our algorithms are
able to manage infrared data you should
be able to manage big amount of data
that is today our data set should have
much bigger amount of objects to
recognize and images in order to train
our algorithms okay today we have data
sets that contain millions of images we
have the image net with 14 millions of
images in thought
with 1 million and half annotated images
but also we have thousands of images
annotated for segmentation and poor
place recognition for medical analysis
even for wasted to detect in the wild
for even images and text in order to
train how to dialogue and how to drive
ok we share a lot of information between
this case for in the generic case but
what about foot what how we charted food
data that we have at this moment at this
moment we have a few data sets that are
public but if you think about all these
data sets we have speaking about 150,000
images at most and as 230 categories at
most so if we compare with other object
revelation where we have at least 1
million and half images annotated and
one hung accountant of cattle to
recognize we see that we are verified so
on the other hand what is the number of
images and what is the number of
categories we need in order to recognize
this is a good question ok so if we try
to make this simple and count a simple
calculus we can see that for today if we
claim to go to 200 thousands of images
to request to recognize we would need
280 million of images and they should be
undertaken so probably we are still not
in this in this device but we should go
forward anyway so today we have a very
powerful technique so we should work on
this and we should try to address this
problem and so this is called deep
learning and deep learning have
different models one of them is the
convolutional neural networks so in the
convolutional neural networks we have a
model that is constructed by some layers
so we have an image that is used as
input and then one layer is used in
order to classify which food we are
speaking about
so the whole process of training
coalition and our networks is how to use
a lot of annotated images in order to
adapt this this way to the different
layers so that when I share a new image
the neuron that is corresponding to the
food category the right neuron is hard
this is this coalition on our networks
in fact one of the first began from
nineteen nineteen ninety-eight but
really the the boost was from 2012 when
Alex net appear today there are a lot of
different deep learning techniques there
are a lot of networks and all of them
they have slightly different
architectures but in all of them they're
the big problem is how to train this
million of parameters that are inside
the neural network so we you can see
that here we have the different the
different architectures of neural
networks and their accuracy so it is
difficult to say which is the best one
but there are few candidates for this
now what makes the different learning
very popular so one change of the the
promise here is that the copies because
in all these different networks in fact
the question is that we train this
network so we did we shouldn't decide on
what the neural network should focus so
the algorithm is able to train us the
baby science kids when we show a lot of
different examples so that the neural
network is able to change how what is
the foot in the image also it is modular
so with mr. mention there are different
architectures we can construct and it is
easier to put another layer to change
layers etc and also it is doing transfer
learning and this is really very
interesting for the transfer learning so
what is transfer learning transfer
rolling is that the ability to reuse
knowledge from one domain to another to
from one problem to another so to try to
explain it metaphorically so maybe you
have seen this one this a movie where
this person lady she has amnesia so she
forgets everything each each night so in
the morning she wake up and wakes up and
she finds a person unknown person in his
in her bed and she should know that this
person is her husband and she should
fall in love in this day and she should
under understand that she has a family
etc and during the night
all these disappear so our algorithms
before were very much I'm nice I'm magic
but now in with deep learning we can
reuse we can reuse from one a problem
from one domain to another and this is
really interesting in in this case so
the penny conned all these possibilities
and we can speak about how to translate
information from one domain to another
how to translate information between
different tasks and how to make the
algorithm to self learn different
possibilities we have for the deep
learning algorithms so here for example
we can see that one of the well-known
and very basic is what to do when we
speak about fine tuning so we train from
one domain to recognize for example here
food from images of food and then we can
reuse this model in order to recognize
objects from real life like cats but
also we can do in different way we can
have a model that is we do the same from
the same image we have different
questions that is we are solving
different recognition problem from this
we can also use another model where we
mix different domains like for example
images and say in text or we can also
try to think as how to to use this model
in order to to generalize this task that
is if we have different tasks that could
be interrelated like for example using
IntelliJ where we put information from
very different kinds and different
different subdomains and different
products on different tasks so in our
case going back to the foot what we do
is we here we have an image and we can
they make different questions so we can
ask what is the cuisine this is one
qualification problem what is the
category this is meal meat another
classification problem what are the
ingredients and other American Pacific
Asian problem like what is the dish
another classification problem so we
share from multitask learning in this
case so multitask learning is a kind of
transfer learning that has shown that is
working very well because it allows to
help the information we extract from one
task to learn to another one and hit our
case what we can do is have this
multitask learning problem where we
combine all different tasks from the
same images from the same domain and try
to see how they help each other the
point is that when we try to put all
this different tasks different
recognition problems in the same model
how do we manage it to control to guide
this different task so for example when
I ask the problem what are the
ingredients definitely this will be much
more difficult to say then for example
if this is a foot or not or what is the
cuisine definitely so in this case I
should also try to guide or to restrict
so that be a task that are more precise
should have more priority in order to
help to the other task and that are very
imprecise a lot of raw error they should
affect much less to the other because
maybe we are worsening the problem so
for this we need to try to see what does
this mean what is the this error in
precision and in this case we speak
about in certainty so the idea is how to
make these priorities express them as a
service so let's talk about a certainty
this is the last the last issue
so when we speak about uncertainty in
our model so in fact what we want to
know is when our model is giving an
answer we want not only to have an
answer but to note that the confidence
with which this answer is given that is
imagine that the reacquisition is using
deep learning algorithm in order to
decide if a person should be preceded
with surgery so it is not the same if
the dip learning says okay this is a
cancer and you should proceed with
surgery
99% of confidence then it is a cancer
but I'm 55% yeah so in this case it is
the same so we need to express and we
need to get this uncertainty about our
models in order to decide how to make
this transfer learning from task to task
and this is the kind of in order to help
not only deep learning to be considered
as black boxes because we try to also
understand how this is reasoning okay
okay so what is uncertainty uncertainty
comes from from different from different
aspects for example a certainty is very
proper to the algorithm just because of
their kind of training that is for
example if I have this eight classes and
I train to my algorithm in order to
recognize apples and strawberries so
what do you think it will be an answer
when I put this image I Paulo strawberry
right because the algorithms have not
intelligent enough in order to say no
but this image is not one of old I was
trained okay this is one kind of
uncertainty this uncertainty is coming
from the data we speak here about a
Alatorre occur in certainty when we
share for example different classes some
of these are with more error and some of
them are with less error so our
algorithm by default they are not
trained it the in order to say okay when
you have this kind of classes well you
should be taken to a candid here we have
much more
and also another error is coming from
the model so if I have the same data but
I use the different models definitely
Munda generalization error and the
regionalization capacity of my model
will be very different different okay so
all of these we and that's why we are
speaking about different kinds of
uncertainty aleatory when it is coming
from the data and epistemic where it is
coming much more from the model okay so
in our case what we do is we have the
image we define this in this way they
that are waiting the different task so
that this way depends on the incident
certainty that is estimated from the
date from the allah toric by uncertainty
okay so in this way what we do is our
more precise our tasks are affecting
less or and affecting more are helping
more to the other task and visible by
service so in our case we have our foot
image method we are constructing and
this image net is the biggest one at
this moment so we have at this moment
ingredients or drinks and food and and
cuisines and also categories and 600 in
total foot classes okay so we are still
far from two hundred thousand but it is
more than what we have today in the
public data so if you have curiosity we
can you can go to triple w dot log meal
dot yes and try to see there are 100,000
foot images well you can see how it is
working so for example you see that in
this cases even in these images we see
that the the dish is well recognized it
even the ingredients in this case were
well recognized it because it is quite
coinciding with the current rate in
green when it is not coinciding with the
ground truth it is in red so definitely
this images it is very difficult to
recognize the ingredients it is logical
and in this for example it is quite more
easy to recognize so for example some of
you will ask how do you recognize
ingredients that are not visible
yeah we don't have them in the image but
we have the multitask learning problem
so we know that when we share one recipe
one dish we know which are the
ingredients they so we use all this
information together in order to help
each other okay so these are the results
where we can see that our model that is
this multitask learning model and here
we have the different possibility I will
not go into details but the purple one
is the best one and that use in
certainty in order to help the the part
of the problem to recognize better so in
this case you see that we used
uncertainty not only to know which is
uncertainty of the final answer but also
to help in the training process so some
result for example here you can see in
this heat map for example you see this
is the these are the regions where our
algorithms use it in order to decide
that it is for example bacon potato it's
going a little bit fast but Africa it is
Rock stick Brussels sprout meatballs
mashed potatoes mashed potatoes pork
steak and pork steak here and chicken
and green beans and
okay and last what we also are working
through this moment is using this
information in order to try to
understand this whole cooking process so
if the idea here is that even if you
have cooking videos that we have a lot
of cooking videos in YouTube out of here
this is our IP kitchen very good public
data set so what we can do is here
recognize the different foods in order
to understand the whole cooking process
okay so conclusion I would say that foot
image work bring cast a huge amount of
data and computer vision challenges and
questions
it makes us redefine which are the data
sets which are the problems which are
the questions which are the answers
which are the methodologies the right
methodologies and run the right
technology and transfer learning is a
good candidate to address this problem
and to solve different subproblems as
for example multi task learning but this
is of course not the only one and the
certainty modeling he is a hot topic at
this moment with many open questions and
challenges and here we have an
illustration how a certainty modeling
help can help improve all models and
give more information than just the
final answer and here we can speak about
a big stomach and aleatory can certainty
a lot of interesting questions and very
active area and a huge impact the food
analysis expected from point of view of
science because we have really new and
challenging problems but also from real
world applications especially important
for the society and that's my talk thank
you for your attention
thank you so much for a speech I would
like to know did you try to solve some a
regression problem for example predict
number of calories or something like
that
thank you good question
okay because we are working at this one
in two [ __ ] trivial problems that is
related to three European project and
there of course the final question is
this how to estimate the final amount of
calories so the final amount of cover is
it depends on not on your own kind of
food depends on the amount and depends
on the way of preparation okay so it's
long process so at this moment and we
are doing this approximately that is
what we do is here we follow as the
initial others who Diaries we mentioned
where you say ok for this foot the
individual dose is so much gram so for
each ingredients and then we have a very
good scientific and nutritional data
basis where you say 100 of carrot
correspond to so much hydro card so much
protein saturated ok that is what that
is it is very difficult to have the
absolute truth from the images yeah but
what we can do is from from this part
what we follow is at least what is done
until now but the process the whole
process is what we recognize is the food
ok and from the food we have the
individual recipes and from the
individual recipes we translate them in
nutritional composition ok but
definitely this is not absolutely true
that is if people put butter or olive
oil they should say this we cannot see
this from day
yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you for your
presentation and to actually two
questions one is about generating
artificially generating data like Sawat
slugs and so it's just a mix of
different ingredients do you try that
approach and the second questions about
recognition you are talking about some
CNN that recognize the categories and a
months ago there was an explanation what
actually arrest net learns about
imagenet and they said that the bass
know which they gain is textures and
shapes so Seth make possibly that is a
good for this task but actually people
usually difference a different object by
shape but not the Czech tech stocks what
do you think about that
good going to the first question yeah
definitely we are also working consensus
I think data but not final results yet
it is not so easy yeah to synthesize the
here data definitely we are now working
on guns also but it is complicated that
is I cannot just get the carrot and put
in another place makhmud but definitely
this is very important and very
interesting question and it takes makes
a lot of sense in order to work on this
about the second question that is well I
I'm I'm not sure that the texture is not
captured in in our case because in food
there is a lot of texture so so I but
definitely it make sense to go to look a
little bit better but I think that at
the end in very much depends on the the
data
understanding in Indian in general I
don't have the right statistic but in
the real world maybe we don't have some
that is the percentage of objects we
have with texture and no texture I don't
know what it is but input texture is
very important and and I'm I'm oh I I
have the intuition that it is captured
by by the algorithm
yeah because otherwise when you have
this kind of rice how do you separate
the different kind of rice from from
other food so texture is important and
food and that shape here in a lot of
food you have just a ball so if you
separate if you discriminate rice from
potato it's based on texture and color
not on shape thanks better for this
lovely speech I have been working in a
project that is closing now that's about
diets my input data is the the kind of
food that people is eating so thank you
very much for working on that because we
were working on on surveys and on the
Declaration of the and inconsistencies
in data so big that is very difficult to
work on that
so two things that I I found in that
project that I don't think if you found
the same as as we found or not one is
that we found that decomposition the
nutritional the composition of prepared
food changes according to the country so
roasted chicken is not the same
nutrition of the composition in Spain
that in United States and this created a
lot of problems in managing these issues
so one question is did you find that as
well and second one is you decided to
approach the thing in a way of
identifying the every single ingredient
on the on the dish but we were following
an approach about working with the
entire prepare foods and my question is
what
easy to tack a dish like roasted chicken
or I don't know vegetable soups instead
of trying to identify every single in
ingredient yes in fact this this is a
multi task lemon so one of the tips we
have the different tasks one is the
cuisine another is the type it is drink
or food or salts also ingredient another
one is the dish and another one is the
ingredients so so we have all these
tasks right and from this data for for
the ingredients what will the heaviest
on one help ingredients are coming from
but I see peas and this is whether a
determinate and on the other one is
coming from there from the images but
definitely we provide to the
nutritionist the information about the
food yeah and then this one this is the
pie
the the patient is can confirm with the
food then it is translated to the
ingredients yeah so so in fact they need
the nutritionist need to do this
statistic to say okay this person is a
gluten oriented yeah because he likes a
pizza pasta etc this person misses
vegetables or this person have very
different Food Lion tired so definitely
this is this is their yeah
[Music]